when you're running a business and you
hire somebody in and it's and maybe you
lost the VP of sales or you had to let
somebody go and you bring someone in the
new guy
first of all is your guy it doesn't
belong to the sales department doesn't
belong to your people the boss brought
in the new guy and so the first thing
you have to do is find a way to win over
the hearts of the people that are there
because you're there because the guy
they liked or the woman they liked got
fired or quit and so the opportunity for
organ rejection is high meaning no one's
going to like this new person no matter
what they do they could walk on water
properly everybody there is upset about
everything that's happened they're upset
at the at the management you and we call
it organ rejection medical term